we are under attack the demon hand of
censorship strikes again opposable will
no censorship is a powerful weapon that
should only be used against a real
threat like Democratic memos or that eye
exam poster that has the secret deep
state message in it but we should never
censor internet truth look at this
latest assault on one of our alt media
brethren YouTube starting to crack down
on a controversial Channel reports say
it gave an info wars Channel its first
strike for sharing various theories
about the school shooting in Florida
YouTube is trying to cut down on hate
speech and fake news by permanently
banning accounts with three strikes in
three months three strikes and you're
out nothing could be less American but
this this is where we are
YouTube claims they gave Infowars their
first strike because they are violating
their content policy by spreading quotes
hate speech and fake news but that's
fake news Infowars has been
truth-telling like this for years since
lizard people first demanded immigration
rights we look what is your tank on on
Sandy Hook and all the people that look
and act like actors I'm sorry folks this
is such a false flag this was such an
attempt to make Trump look bad you look
at the Aurora shooting that was totally
staged Alex Jones says the things no one
else would because only he dares to
stoop so brave that's why the
establishment comes after him like this
everyone has it in for Alex Jones CNN
MSNBC cholesterol
and now there's a new narc yep and at
his heels
and a few days ago Jones called him out
by name Jordan Kepler what's his name
Josh Kepler or something and I don't
just act like cool like I don't know he
is I don't watch this Kepler there are
10 shows we know of homeland Kepler will
attack us five nights a week and who say
things we never said Kepler is again
like the classic psychopath in school
and he's just lording and enjoying the
lies Kepler is a failed actor so there's
another dropping of Soros yeah you heard
that right there's a failed actor out
there on Comedy Central who's attacking
Alex Jones and his name is Jordan
Keppler this guy sounds like a dick he's
handsome for a SOI boy I'll give him
that
you look at that guy and you see army
hammer without all the flashy muscles
and the grandstanding jawbone you know
he's got a forehead that goes all the
way up but don't be fooled this guy is
bad news he's deep state I did a little
digging and if he's an actor why does
IMDB claim he does not exist
because Kepler is too smart he scrubbed
the database but Alex Jones never lets a
total lack of evidence stop him from
reporting the truth here's the crazy
thing
Jones is upset because this Jordan
Kepler criticized Infowars for reporting
crisis actors were employed after the
parklands shooting the same claims that
got him his first YouTube strike
what's even more wild the same night
this Kepler guy was attacking Infowars
our show hosted by me Jordan Klepper was
very sincerely defending Infowars for
that same story this Kepler is a
disgusting deep state mole also it
sounds like he has some real gastric
problems the point is is that diarrhea
coming out of a wart infested but Kepler
is a joke I mean this is that parasite
that reads on the teleprompter diarrhea
coming out of somebody's ass a tumor in
your MRI let's go back to turn blossom
here's Lord Kepler yeah whoa it sounds
to be fair it sounds gross but turned
blossoms were actually the flowers at my
first wedding
clearly Jones knows how to win an
argument what I worry about is that the
folks at YouTube won't listen to reason
if left unchecked this Kepler might draw
attention to other Infowars videos that
YouTube could use as an excuse to ban
them things like proof Boston Marathon
bombing is staged terror attack or the
Orlando shooting was a false flag or the
war on male vitality exposed special
reports hard-hitting reporting the fact
is Alex Jones is facing a potential
banned from YouTube because of the
things his show said now is that his
fault no it's the fault of people like
Jordan Kepler opposers don't let the
mainstream media and Kepler win can't
pay off your student loans well whose
choice was it's a major musical poetry
blame Kepler someone farted in the
elevator you're alone in blame Kepler
he's literally made of diarrhea get your
YouTube channel shut down for violating
their policy on hate speech thus
drastically reducing your vitamin
supplement revenue stream blame kepler
opposers we need to spread the word
tweet at real Alex Jones all the things
that Jordan Kepler has ruined so he
knows - hashtag blame Kepler because if
there's not a shadowy figure on the
horizon who you can blame all your
problems on then the problem is you and
that sounds like some crazy conspiracy
theory
[Music]